laurent philippot pense qu'il faut tout
ouvrir jean paul hamon médecins non il
faut tout laisser fermer et mon jean
paul pendant la pause là il m'a dit
cyril passe moi le ballon parce que là
il faut que je n'achète pas bien qu'est
ce qui se passe me jean-paul écoutez moi
le lors du premier camp finement j'ai
été le premier à dire qu'il fallait
rouvrir les plages les parts que les
forêts parce que c'était une connerie de
tout laisser fermer mais là on à 5900
personnes en réanimation et ça grimpe
d'accord vouloir dire qu'il faut tout
rouvrir
ça c'est vraiment de la folie pure c'est
de la provocation c'est vraiment aller
racler les fonds de tiroir essayé de
ramasser les complotistes parce qu'il ya
des élections etc
il ya un moment il faut arrêter de
déconner quoi hein moi je suis pour
qu'on roule les terrasses les terrasses
je suis pour qu'on trouve les musées au
tiers de les magasins puisque lé magasin
de mine de rien de vêtements par exemple
dans des dents des jeux vous dit
jean-paul je le disais la dent la fois
un magasin de vêtements dans une petite
ville ou dans des villes voilà même
normal y voit là franchement ils ne sont
pas 50 personnes dans les magasins moi
j'ai ça fait maintenant deux mois que
qu'olivier ferrand c'est une cabine
castex et qu' il ya des purificateurs
d'air qui détruisent le virus détruisent
de virus ils sont sans l'aimer faire les
magasins à briquet à nantes
personne personne du gouvernement elle
est allée vérifier ça or ça sécuriserait
sa sécuriserait des classes parce que sa
publicité génial savaria purifie les six
mètres carrés deux mètres cinquante de
hauteur à sécuriserait des classes à
sécuriserait les petits commerces ça
pourrait même peut-être ouvrir des
restaurants
ça coûte d'accord un roi 5 août 5 août
1500 euros là mais c'est bien moins cher
que j'en appelle à ceux qui ont fait ça
est ce qui peut venir 2 - demain en
témoin du jour pour qui nous en parle et
pour qu'on fasse un appel au
gouvernement demain avec eux dans
l'émission en direct parce que ça c'est
vraiment ça chez un truc ce n'est pas
dans ma dressage il allait plus on va
tenir demain contre installés ils sont
venus les installer dans mon cabinet la
semaine dernière ils sont bien salée
dans mon cabinet la semaine dernière et
ils sont en train de fabriquer des
petits boîtiers de 15,15 qu'on peut
poser sur une table qui sécurise sur une
surface de 15 mètres carrés et tous
aillent sur un volume de 2 c'est ça je
ne le savais pas voilà le gouvernement
n'a pas bougé parce qu'il dit les
purificateurs d'air ça ne marche pas or
is as
pire l'air et ils détruisent le virus
par paris peroxydation dans le boîtier
et c'est complètement différent de
génial réplicateurs d'air qu'on peut
avoir
ça fait deux mois que le gouvernement le
sait et il ne bouge pas c'est ça qui me
rend fou racks d'un accord voilà c'est à
raison j'en suis aussi il a fallu
vraiment gueuler comme des veaux pour
obtenir le droit de faire cette dose
avec les flyers alors qu'on était
capables qui avait aucune différence
entre la première et la 7e doses il a
fallu gueuler pour le faire mais pour
l'obtenir avant le droit de le faire et
un droit d'injecter alors qu' aucune
différence entre la première et 7e dose
et là sur les purificateurs d'air c'est
pareil mais dire qu'il faut tout ouvrir
ça pour moi c'est criminel
les réalisations sont pleines monsieur
philippe au temps quand on est en direct
ouvrir depuis qu'est ce que vous voulez
qu'on choisit sans mes sincères que les
réanimateurs que les régulateurs soit 90
mais attendent à lui enlever leurs
animateurs mais la situation de choisir
qui vont rennais mais ou pas monsieur
hamon un regard des gens nous regardent
et ça vous regarde ça avec comme nous en
norvège ouais 60 ans il a fait un
rassemblement comme vous sans masque 1
c'était un complotiste
il est mort de la commission d'accord
qu'il y soit on a continué comme ça
c'est bien vous m'aviez dit l'autre soir
il aurait fini pour fermer assez de lits
à l'hôpital vous êtes toujours d'accord
sur le fait mais je suis je suis
d'accord vous pour se souvenir mais
aussi parce que l'art la réforme des
systèmes de santé n'a pas n'a pas eu
lieu
là les hôpitaux les unités de savoir à
ses personnels
or ce les émissions vous avez souvent
pourquoi n'y a pas cette année lorsqu'on
occupe les hospitaliers parce qu'on
occupe les hospitaliers à des à des
fonctions qui pourraient être faites en
ville bien moins cher c'est à dire qu'on
surveille des maladies chroniques qui
sont et qu'ils voulaient fermer des
l'ont fait les écoles de l'asthme ont
fait des écoles de l'asthme et ce
personnel là il serait bien plus utile
dans les services il se passe quelque
chose en saône et loire je crois ou là
on vient de mettre des paramédicaux dans
les ambulances de réanimation c'est à
dire des gens qui sont capables d'amener
en moins de vingt minutes les gens à
l'hôpital
là où il ya des vrais services d'urgence
si à paris aussi dans toutes les grandes
agglomérations
cyril si dans toutes les grandes
agglomérations où on est à moins de 20
minutes d'un vrai service d'urgence des
paramédics qui sont formés qui
transporte le type et qui l'amène à
l'hosto en moins de vingt minutes
imaginez le
nombre de réanimateurs qui serait
seulement dans les services hospitaliers
voilà ce qu'il faut à la vraie réforme
mais c'est à côté de la vraie réforme
celle de 120 à paris